physical intelligence as described by
authors claire dale and patricia payton
is a measure of a person's
self-awareness and self-mastery
this is almost synonymous with the
related term enteroception
which is the capacity to monitor and
thus influence
your own physiological state which may
in turn impact our mood and performance
it's a really interesting concept and
the cool part is that it's something
that can be trained and improved
doing so can have direct and amazing
benefits for your health cognitive
performance
relationships athleticism and more
recently more and more people have been
championing the importance of eq
eq is your emotional quotient or your
emotional intelligence and is supposed
to measure your ability to understand
and work with the emotions of
others this has further been extended to
include a knowledge and control of one's
own emotions
i just uploaded an in-depth post on this
over at thebioneer.com
so i highly recommend you go and check
that out but while eq is certainly
important it can actually be seen as
merely a facet of something even more
important
physical intelligence another way to
think about this is as
knowing how to understand and use your
own body and if this sounds like
something you should already know how to
do
then well yeah but nevertheless it's
also something a lot of us struggle with
it's something we rarely think about and
it certainly doesn't get taught in
schools
an example that i like to give is
getting hungry most of us know that we
become irritable when we're hungry
but being physically intelligent would
mean recognizing when this has happened
understanding why it has happened and
knowing how to deal with it
so why do we get hungry the answer has
to do with the relationship between
glucose
tryptophan cortisol and serotonin see
when you've just eaten a big
carb-packed meal you also increase
levels of tryptophan
this is an essential amino acid that is
also a precursor to serotonin
that means that the brain can use it to
synthesize serotonin
tryptophan also has the ability to cross
the blood-brain barrier
via a carrier protein what this means is
that after a big meal the brain is high
in serotonin
you've probably heard serotonin referred
to as the happiness hormone
indeed serotonin is both a hormone and a
neurotransmitter
that encourages feel good emotions and
helps us to relax
over time serotonin has broken down to
create melatonin the sleep hormone
which is why we feel content and drowsy
after a big meal
but as you start to use up the available
energy and glucose drops
so too do your serotonin levels moreover
the body begins to release epinephrine
adrenaline
glucagon growth hormone and cortisol
this makes sense the body needs glucose
as its primary energy source
these chemicals help to modulate the
body's response to low blood sugar
glucagon dissipates insulin for example
but it also helps to raise plasma
glucose
concentrations by stimulating liver
glucose production
while simultaneously making the
individual more driven and focused
in other words if you feel a bit
stressed then you're more likely to go
out and try to find food
but most people have a constant access
to food and don't need to go into fight
or flight mode
to start hunting and gathering so
instead we simply become
moody that's when our partner who is
also hungry
shouts us us for leaving the washing up
and we bark back with a disproportionate
response
before you know it you're bringing up
personal insults and things that
happened years ago
and then you both feel awful the
physically intelligent individual
would understand that their thoughts
might be a little extra negative
owing to their hunger and might
therefore decide to postpone their
heated response they might understand
how to restore calm balance to their
autonomic nervous system
in the short term by using breathing
techniques or they might use cognitive
behavioral therapy to calm their racing
thoughts
they might even galvanize that nervous
energy and put it to good use by tidying
the house while their food cooks
thus a little more physical intelligence
in this one regard can potentially help
a person to avoid arguments
improve their relationships and even
improve their performance
emotional intelligence meanwhile comes
from understanding that your other half
might also be hungry or tired or anxious
eq means recognizing this and therefore
giving them the benefit of the doubt
well um i i i said i'm sorry
you are going to face justice and may it
be kinder to you than it was to us
autobots transform and
roll for hall in the workplace this kind
of emotional intelligence and
self-management is critical
from delivering the best speech by
understanding how to get your physiology
under control
to managing people better by
understanding how to coax the best
performance out of them
cortisol levels and negative emotions
are not straightforward and directly
correlated though
hopefully this example has helped to
demonstrate just how complex this
interplay of biological processes and
chemicals really
is this is one reason that using drugs
can be destructive
it's why neurotropics that are supposed
to make you smarter unfortunately are
not the answer
you can take a 5-htp supplement
5-hydroxytryptophan
in order to become more socially relaxed
but this is also going to risk making
you a little slower
seeing a serotonin melatonin are both
inhibitory substances
the same goes for modafinil often called
the real limitless drug
modafinil works on orexin and dopamine
which in turn regulates sleep wake
cycles alongside bowel movements energy
levels appetite and more
it's no wonder that the powerful drug
that prevents sleep will also
suppress appetite and force you to keep
running to the toilet
while taking adderall to boost your
focus is not a physically intelligent
solution to your problems then there are
other safer ways to hack your physiology
to ensure you perform optimally when you
need to but here are just
some examples of controlling your
physiology splashing your face with cold
water to activate the mammalian diving
reflex
taking a cold shower to increase
alertness using power poses
although not all studies have been able
to verify how effective this strategy is
avoiding light from screens just before
bed to avoid spiking cortisol
drinking coffee to boost alertness
knowing when to stop drinking coffee
changing your physiological state and
mood by listening to or dancing to music
this is ideal for getting more energy
when you need to be more productive but
you're beginning to flag
remembering to actively relax muscles
during tense moments
manipulating meal timings to mitigate
the effects of jet lag
or my favorite exercising throughout the
day this has been one of the most
profound changes i've made to my own
life
and it's transformed my own energy
levels performing pull-ups and push-ups
continuously
ensures that i don't suffer from sensory
motor amnesia while keeping my
metabolism up and increasing strength
in each case you're listening to your
own body and combining this with a
knowledge of how it works
in order to eke out greater performance
and even happiness
just be wary of some bio hacks i want to
make a post on biohacking in future
but suffice to say that not all advice
you hear from biohacking gurus
is equally as effective some of these
strategies are expensive and time
consuming for very little reward
others are based on poor understanding
of the science and can even be harmful
it's also useful to recognize that
everyone is different some people don't
get angry so much as nervous and shaky
that's me
physical intelligence also means knowing
how you personally respond and thus
acting ahead
for example if you know that you start
getting hungry about three hours after a
big meal
then perhaps that could tell you how to
plan out your meals a bit better on a
big day
we can likewise think about chronotype
in this context different people
function better
at different times of day in one study
100 metre race performance varied as
much as 26
based on the individual's chronotype and
the time of day the run took place
of course interroction is the result of
many different systems working together
an obvious culprit is the vagus nerve
which handles communication between
autonomic functions and the brain
this is how breathing rapidly is able to
alter stress levels for example
then there are less direct connections
such as the aforementioned role of
tryptophan after eating
and we know how gut bacteria can
likewise contribute to the production of
neurotransmitters that alter mood and
even metabolism
the anterior cingulate cortex appears to
be one of the brain regions
most responsible for mediating
interoceptive attention
this area works alongside the insula of
the cerebrum which is responsible for
the sense of self and emotional state
but one of the most surprising sources
of interreception is the fascia
you didn't think i was going to get a
whole video without mentioning fascia
did you
fascia as i've discussed on the bioneer
several times before
is a kind of sheath of connective tissue
that is found throughout the human body
we now know that it contains its own
smooth muscle cells that may help
contribute towards healthy movement
but even more fascinating is that it is
actually riddled with nerve endings
many of these nerve endings are
proprioceptors suggesting the muscle
fascia
may contribute to our mental model of
our own body
but we now also know that the fascia
likely contains seven times more
enteroceptors these are three nerve
endings that have countless crucial
roles
among which is to provide feedback
regarding states such as hunger and
warmth
to regulate emotional responses in fact
the human visceral fascia which helps to
suspend organs within their cavities
contains countless nerves that link
directly to the insular showing how
things like hunger and fatigue
can directly impact on mood these
sensations are also used in our
development of gut feelings and
intuition
handled by large and densely connected
brain cells called spindle cells
these cells are considered crucial for
social abilities but are also key in
steering behavior based on visceral
reactions
and similar abilities of the superficial
fascia show us why massaging hugging
stroking and tickling
can all result in emotional responses
keep in mind that all these signals are
then interpreted in a highly
context-sensitive manner
that is to say that a light stroke on
the leg can be interpreted as arousing
ticklish or deeply upsetting depending
on the context
the same goes for your sense of fatigue
or arousal and this is one reason why
you can quickly make someone extremely
angry by asking them why are you so
angry today
this is an example of biohacking another
person
interreception is just one of the senses
that we often overlook another is
proprioception
or body sense this is our kinesthetic
awareness
our knowledge of where our body is in
space at any given time interreception
and proprioception are extremely closely
linked and in many cases the line is
blurred
for example many people carry a lot of
stress with them but don't even realize
it
as we know a fight or flight response
increases muscle tension
and so we sit there with jaws clenched
and shoulders raised
this can lead to pain and discomfort but
it also further elevates stress
seeing as the communication between
these signals is a two-way street
being stressed makes us clench up and
being clenched up makes us more stressed
so i ask you where are your shoulders
right now are you clenching your jaw
even if you don't think you are try
actively relaxing and you might be
surprised how much more relaxed you
could have been
this of course can be highly beneficial
for athletes wasting energy by walking
around like a giant clenched fist
is not conducive to optimal performance
even personality has an impact here
a huge impact in fact of course a more
stressed person will carry more tension
with them
and this has benefits as well as
downsides you can then learn
different amounts of tonus to carry with
you so that your muscles are more or
less relaxed by default
want to know something crazy but logical
when you think about it extroverts
actually have faster reaction times
according to multiple studies
tom myers in a conversation with dr
robert schlepp gave a fascinating
example of keeping your arm raised for a
long period of time
proprioception is what tells you where
your arm is but the overwhelming urge to
lower the arm as it gets tired
is an example of interoception this
shows how these two systems work
together
this is emotional and based on inputs
such as heat and hydrogen buildup
this is something that all bodybuilders
should be rather familiar with
myers went on to describe this as a kind
of battle between your own
interroceptive feedback
who wins the fascia telling you that you
need to eat or your own will
a key takeaway here is that all of these
systems are links and intertwined
everything from our personality to our
physical strength to our reaction times
to our gut bacteria
to our proprioception to how hungry we
are to the environment around us
there's constant communication between
all of these shifting and changing
systems
a truly transformative training program
should recognize the system as a whole
so with all that said how can you
improve your interception and your
ability to recognize what your body is
telling you
so that you can work with it rather than
against it exercising and especially
improving proprioception can help a lot
as we've seen this is very closely
linked with interreception
and will help you to better be aware of
what your body is doing at any given
time
using biofeedback is another great
strategy that means using heart rate
monitors and fitness trackers
to tell you how things like heart rate
are changing by being aware of this
you can then learn to recognize the cues
from your own body without needing an
external device
one study showed that when subjects were
required to check their own heart rate
regularly throughout the day they'd
eventually learn the ability to control
their own heart rate
at will meditation of course can also
help us to choose how to focus our
attention
and to work through certain sensations
where appropriate
cognitive behavioral therapy can help us
to change the context of sensations
in order to manage our emotional
response to them but the rest is
learning
the more you understand about the way
your body works and the different
physiological systems involved
the more you can intellectualize the
sensations you're interpreting
hopefully you'll leave this video a
little more physically intelligent than
you were before
and a little more aware of your
interreception than you began
so i hope you found this video useful
and interesting guys if you did then
please leave a like and share around
that helps me out immensely thank you so
much for watching this one
subscribe if you want much more like
this and leave a comment below
letting me know how you use
interoception and physical intelligence
in your own life as you guys know i
currently have a book
for pre-order on amazon and many other
retailers that's called functional
training and beyond
and that book explores the origins and
the impact of functional training
techniques
it looks at many different forms of
training and shows how to combine them
in a way
that makes them more applicable to
everyday life
and taking performance beyond just the
ordinary
alternatively i also have an e-book and
training program called super functional
training
you can find a link to that in
description below there's a discount on
right now so we're all in lockdown
and that's basically a full training
program and massive guide that discusses
all the things i talk about on this
training
and combines it into a single program to
improve physical and mental performance
either way i hope you guys are all
staying safe and well thank you so much
for watching this
and i'll see you next time bye for now